I same energy blow of it stay a little
bit I did my thing
I get busy I watch them cuz it didn't
bring me still when it's mine in my face
I've seen gravy I don't know funny cuz a
big man told me don't be a little baby
yeah you best move out the way work out
and then I save the page and now I
showed up number thought these haters
trying to find why I say if I might just
say peril you could blend in and still
see the camera so much fake love when I
go about busting the bow and arrow not
be our rent to settle to sugar chair
when I bought the Kelly brothers on that
book control but it want to roll around
with heavy metal don't hate cause I make
that sound still to be here when I need
you pounds
low-key I'm moving about keeping it ins
and I ran this down flashbacks today
when I break me then not now I ain't got
time for the chitchat for you on the
beach with you in a whiplash payday but
I still wanna make ration or shouldn't I
shouldn't have said that
why cuz I haven't got [ __ ] for the
moment you want to chat rich and get
trapped in a bubble get popped by a
Hammond on Westham I say thank you for
my breath and I still but plan to pay
for another man thank you for my mom's
and my dad's and I've got a bill
transform I saw in another hand bless
suck my balls in it ends this in a trap
already but on another path I know it's
all mad out here when minimum wage will
you shut up for a next month and you
wanna be calm out here but I'm used to
check if you like nips man say more
stories snip their bridges and they do
it for a next man secure their one that
stands no passion and drive matches on
to the next man same old faces ktg da
ting in our way by our next man yes I
grew up in London South Westerley done
good looks and feels might take me out
my store stack up for abundance yes just
do your tingle my kings and queens just
do your tea no I saw a movie ting but
you wanna act up in this movie tink ya
just do your ting my king
just do your team make sure when you get
to the top you secure the energy that
you bring
[Music]